everyone welcome to LED live the show
where we exposed the darkness in this
world with the light of Christ how is
the New Age deceiving people today find
out on this episode of LED live everyone
welcome to the show and today we have a
guest we have Leah from Michigan thank
you for joining us again she is wearing
our very cool t-shirt great appear
haters make sure you check out our
t-shirts on t spring of course we have
ones like these too that promote our
show LED live I think Mikey's got one
over there too
it's that kill your TV one so check out
our merch we appreciate it and if you
don't know what a patron is we encourage
you to check out patreon where you can
sign up and help support this work and
you can see we have different reward
levels you can catch behind the scenes
action you can catch our extra shows
where we have a post show I think this
one's gonna have a post show and so we
just encourage you to check it out check
out our website little light Studios TV
slash shop where we have many
documentaries most of which are not on
YouTube if they are we didn't put them
there but you can also get those on
Vimeo if you like higher quality digital
downloads where you can buy it you can
rent it so we encourage you to check
those out and of course we appreciate
your comments so make sure you let us
know what you think of a show you have
any questions we read them we respond to
them so ask us your questions and we'd
be happy to do our best to answer those
and so today we're gonna talk about the
New Age again with Leah she gave her
testimony last time and so now we want
to find out what kind of deception is
the New Age propagating today like how
do we see that in today's world can you
share some of what's going on yeah the
new earth deception is something that's
really big right now just the new earth
fifth dimensional time line shift so
it's seen as an existence of you know
we're in this 3d reality
we have to escape and get to this fifth
dimensional reality where so I have a
question right up where the fourth
dimension go skipped over I think some
people see the fourth dimension as this
like portal tour to the fifth dimension
and and then there's higher and higher
dimensions past that but probably ends
at 66 yeah I first heard about this like
the 2012 Mayan calendar type thing I
don't know if it all had to do with the
Mayan calendar but there's a thing about
2012 was I gonna be a big shift in
consciousness and great paradigms and
that's still kind of discussed as that
was like the point of awakening right so
that shift was like okay now it's time
for humanity to awaken to its inherent
divinity and there's gonna be you know
volunteer souls that reincarnate into
Earth and how the Ascension process help
awaken people to this idea that they're
divine that they can create their
reality and then they can liberate
themselves from this lower dimensional
existence it sounds like the matrix it
does but it's like you know the new
earth I believe in a new earth I mean
like I'm I'm hopeful that there's going
to be a new earth this this planets for
the birds man recreated for sure yeah
that's interesting okay
so we're heading towards this supposed
fifth dimensional reality wool and we're
all supposed to wake up and realize that
we're gods then what so then the whole
idea is you have to do service to others
service to others to help awaken
humanity and in order to do that and it
sounds like a great idea like I want to
help other people and that's how that's
where I was I wanted to help other
people you know you see people suffering
from anxiety depression and these things
that I was doing were helping me and so
I wanted to help others and but service
to others so means first servicing
yourself you know lifting yourself up
building yourself up working on yourself
healing yourself integrating your shadow
all of these things to build yourself up
and then by living the life that you
love it will trickle out to other people
and they'll see you know a reflection of
themselves in you and then they'll start
to wake up themselves you can see how I
mean that sounds on the surface like
sounds really good it would be great
like that this would be a positive thing
you you want to see make yourself
healthy and happy and everything and
whenever people see your joy then they
want to say well I like what good weight
you got going on in your life I want
some of that how do I get that perfect
counter fit for Christianity all right
isn't that crazy
like the New Age it really is share so
many common denominators with
Christianity that it's just a kilter
just like a little bit off and that off
I think is the whole idea of the
divinity and and our place in this whole
thing it's like when Christ came to this
earth there was like he wasn't getting
anything out of it and he's going around
helping others and healing them and and
helping them realize who they are in
Christ you know not who they are as
divinity but who they are in him and so
I see a lot of similarities like you're
saying but but it's not it's not about
me it's not this not self focused at all
excellent point something I hadn't
really thought about Jesus getting
tempted right
he gets offered everything you know in
sort of the New Age movement he'd be
like if I had everything then I could
help other people and do this and that's
kind of the mentality that you'd have
right hmm so you're you're kind of
constantly working on yourself and you
just become a little bit you know
self-absorbed but in an unconscious way
you don't really see it because the
service to others that Christ taught was
a sacrificial service to others putting
others before yourself in sort of the
cart before the horse kind of exactly
putting others before yourself you know
helping the poor helping you know and in
this new earth it's it's you can tap
into this fifth dimensional existence
now by having the state of abundance
love unity unity consciousness and the
3d reality is all about duality good and
evil you know control and you have to
behave this way you know as Christians
like they all have to behave a certain
way and do the ten commandments and all
these things like rules but there is no
good and evil you know it's all just the
universe trying to experience itself and
explore different facets and you know
you can't have the light without the
dark and so it's kind of a yin yang
philosophy yeah
and that's probably why like Eastern
influence really has you know kind of a
hand-in-hand with this just to make sure
I'm understanding this correctly are you
saying that the third dimension is where
people are trapped into like the rules
and all of that and the fifth dimension
is more like liberation and freedom and
free for all right and then the fifth
dimension is more like heaven on earth
and bringing this this existence where
everybody can do the things that they
love and you know affect others and
commune with others but they're all kind
of doing their own thing and we can live
in abundance so we're not worried about
money or you know where food is coming
from and we just kind of were in the
flow you know a utopian idea exactly so
the question is is the fifth dimension
does it have anything to do with the
fifth element I'm not sure because you
find the fifth element in witchcraft you
know it's kind of like this this
pinnacle idea you have to bring all
these things together you know have this
ultimate force and so I'm like hearing
the number five and it's like they have
common parallels and in what they're
trying to achieve that both really
selfish in nature so I'm just wondering
if maybe is their connection they're
definitely seeing the Gnosticism though
it's like that's what Lucifer said is
like you're bound in this garden but I
can free your mind like The Truman Show
you know you're in this dome or what
I can get you out yeah definitely seeing
that the same parallel there yeah yeah
hmm so the fifth element obviously we've
kind of covered this in our in our talks
and stuff with other movies earth wind
fire you know the soul being the fifth
element and sort of you manipulating the
elements to bend you know all of life to
your will and that's like you know what
ultimately you know gives you that
freedom right yeah it's kind of those
same ideas but I had never heard of the
fifth yeah it's like Satan has a you
know he's got a flavor for every person
oh you're not into Wicca hey I knew it
we're alike right yeah yeah a lot of
Hollywood is New Age and I think that
they're probably attracted to it because
they are treated like gods and you know
if you have that kind of like seed
that's planted like you know we just saw
some arm of divinity or you know we're
all kind of connected to this this
divine thing together then it's like
they see themselves like whoa the people
are worshipping you know me and I'm just
realizing Who I am and you know you
watch enough videos from from Jim Carrey
and you're just like wow this guy's like
out there but they're attracted the New
Age movement for sure yeah it's really
interesting that this movement probably
hates the idea that there's no such
thing as good and evil yeah it's like
they have to remove that idea of evil so
that when they come and approach people
it's like people there's no such thing
as evil you know that's kind of like you
have to get that out of your head that
there is such a thing as evil or
darkness you know but it's not so
there's no moral line I mean there is a
moral line but it's it's defined by you
know yourself like you know don't go out
and kill people or don't judge people or
you know all these things but you know
Christ teaches us that to to love each
other don't judge each other you know
help each other Servier and but he has
his moral righteousness about him that
we are striving to achieve that's
something that when he came into my life
that's something I desire his
righteousness what about the person who
sees viewing us
he's killing as a good thing would they
say well that's your truth that's your
consciousness like there's no right and
wrong I don't I don't think so I think
they would say you shouldn't kill people
if if there's no right and wrong you're
looking at everything as good
what good is so subjective to the person
you know heroin is good so I mean it
makes me feel good so let me just take
it right ya know they would see nicotine
it's like oh you want to smoke like oh
cool do your thing
or you know maybe it would be more like
if you want to kill someone
okay fine but now you have to suffer the
consequences because we collectively
agree that we shouldn't do that and
you're kind of going towards this unity
consciousness where we all kind of
partake in abundance and interesting you
said because we agree on it so there is
a collective agreement or like a
unspoken standard you just like you
can't say the words this is bad and but
on what that is if you have a collective
mindset of what morality is then
morality can shift with the collective
mindset the simple topic of sexuality I
mean it's definitely you know a
hot-button topic but you know if it's
been viewed a certain way with through
Christianity for so long and then all of
a sudden our culture swings to another
way and it's like well no that's not
right now this is right that moral line
is gonna constantly shift you know where
I think that God has an absolute truth
that is a moral line that you know is
how we define it fascinating yeah okay
so there's this idea of this five d new
earth and we're all working towards this
consciousness there is no good and evil
there's just like this light in the
darkness this yin-yang idea and where
does all this go I think it goes towards
the let's see the path of Ascension okay
that's that so this is where you get
people awakening you know you want
people to awaken to their divinity and
the path of ascension is getting rid of
these limiting beliefs that hold you
back so then you can ascend into the
higher dimensional what are these
limiting beliefs what do I need to not
believe anymore
well I think that would be like limiting
beliefs is like be having a deity or God
outside of yourself and you have to get
rid of that belief and say that you are
divine and that you are loved and you
know acts the first commandment right
there
think think about what Lucifer said in
heaven right I mean he's literally
saying okay God I can be a moral agent
outside of you I don't have to follow
what you're doing and I can still be
loved even like you that's why Isaiah
when it talks about you know how at the
phone from heaven Oh Lucifer the son of
the morning how to cut down to the
ground because I was weakened the
nation's right he says I wanted to be
like the Most High
what's the most high like he's loved
right so what is Lucifer really saying I
can be loved being without following
your rules and I can be my own moral
agent and I can choose my a loom or
allottee outside of what you think I
need to follow that's that's the life
and that's what the story tonight it's
fascinating they're so close
side-by-side God wants us to be loved he
wants us to be caring he wants that to
lose out of us as if it's within us but
we can't achieve that without him that's
the one distinctive it's like 90
something percent poison mmm just a tiny
little bit of error - it's like and most
of this is good stuff I mean listening
to you talk yes I want to help other
people right yes I want to like you know
realize Who I am in the grand scheme of
the universe right I'm a human being a
child of God like if I don't have that
perspective then what's the point of
what I'm doing here on earth right so
they're tapping into all these like
milestones but it's like it's just off
just enough to basically take the focus
off of God and put it on yourself that's
all that's needed yeah so when when
essentially you re coming your own God
and then you don't really need salvation
anymore right you're essentially your
own Savior that seems like a really
scary place to be yeah anytime I get
into Bates with people whether they're
atheist or some other belief system
they're they always try to make you feel
like you're enslaved to this Christian
box or whatever but it's like I don't I
don't see that I'm enslaved anything
what I'm a slave to loving my neighbor
and loving your enemy as yourself like
when I started throwing that stuff out
I'm they kind of like they don't really
know what to say or where to go because
I how can you hate love you know when I
often tell people what exactly is it
about Jesus Christ himself the first
time Jesus Christ what exactly do you
have a problem with he went around and
healed everybody he went and you know
just everything he did was good you
can't hate on any of it even to the
point where he's on the cross saying
father please forgive them and and
that's where they are like yeah I don't
really know they don't know where to go
that they just know that they don't want
to be held accountable for their actions
so I got to get rid of God and become my
own God so that I can justify what I'm
doing basically ultimate love is giving
yeah right ultimate love is for God so
loved the world that gave His only
begotten Son the definition is white
like you know when we talk about love
versus lust like you look at a vampire
movie right lust is I need to take this
from you I need to suck your blood and
did and take your life that's not love
but the way that they spin it is look at
their lustfully loving so they're kind
of like under the same garb as like love
but it's really the total polar opposite
of love and this is what I see is
happening here with this it's like it's
like love is this very like giving that
God is giving so much to us and then
it's like you know instead of us like
you know giving our lives back to god
it's like nomina I'm gonna keep my life
I'm gonna build up my life so that I can
realize I'm God and I don't need
something outside of me mm-hmm
if you haven't checked out Leah's
testimony please go watch that video
it's one of our LED live episode it's so
powerful but here I have a question you
were talking previously on that you got
into it started with an R wakie yes and
that has some placement in the New Age
right but in the in your experience with
three
and you would have these out-of-body
experiences and you're meditating but
your talk you're talking to these um
what did you call it the spirit guides
exactly so it's interesting how although
they claim that you know they're divine
their God and they're making their
decisions they're still consulting with
spirits or some kind of spiritual
element is that true
right yeah so it's it's kind of seeing
that these spirit guides are also part
of the unity consciousness and we're
this kind of like leg piece of the
puzzle that needs to kind of catch up to
the rest of the universe and that's
where you get et beings that like want
to come and assist in the ascension so
that they can also experience the
benefits of us raising our consciousness
something that there's still that in
need of something outside of ourselves
yeah something higher right so then you
get there and then and then what yeah
you got a a key time did you ever get to
the point where you feel like you
arrived mmm no you don't that's the
point it's like and it's and it's seen
as it's like evolving journey right it's
a journey of self-discovery so
ultimately leading you back to the
Christ consciousness when you reach that
that level of I mean there's no end of
the game like what's that what's I think
the end may just be that you know source
expands so much that then it just
collapses back on itself and then starts
all over again you turn into an orb
because I've heard you know again
atheists are like well eternity would
get boring anyway eventually when you've
done everything but if you're just in
this ever-growing evolution then that
would sound appealing whereas we know
that eternity is never gonna get boring
I mean right I think all the places
you've never got to travel and all the
things that you've never get to do
because of what we're having to do now
but not only all that exploring God's
creation but we might get to see God
create new life like the Angels solve
you know earth get created so we don't
know what God's got in store for
eternity yeah it's not gonna be boring
though no yeah I mean the idea I often
would just think you know the we are
gonna be am bath
for what God's government's gonna be
like I mean we know just from the book
of Job that there's other worlds that
were created right all the sons of God
came and met together and that's when
Lucifer Kaman and so it's like all these
other worlds are gonna constantly come
up to you and be like oh my goodness you
lived in that message like what was that
like you know your life is the testimony
yeah and I mean they're gonna be sitting
there with just popcorn this me you know
III definitely am looking forward to a
new world so do you see any other
deceptions out there in the New Age
being propagated today I mean we've
talked about this path of ascension is
there anything else I mean the New Age
is so hard to define because it's so
much of everything just kind of boiled
into one you know title we see a lot in
Hollywood mm-hmm so do you see the same
sort of thing cartoons books children's
literature like oh yeah here we go right
what do we have here and you know they
have the baby books with meditation
astrology chakras and you know astrology
especially in the way that it's
portrayed to us in society's off
self-focused it's not we look to the
heavens to see signs of God and you know
what he's done and what he's created and
his story it's all about you know what
is my life gonna be like and one of the
stars say about me and it's very
self-focused and then meditation as a
baby you know when you're meditating
from that age and you're just so good at
it and then the crystals aren't
inherently bad on their own but when you
put you know ideas that they're healing
yeah
they have healing powers you know I
think these spirits can work through
that to have healing potential because
some people do see these work and I
think that there's something behind it
but God has the healing power we don't
need crystals to heal yeah when the
enemy sees you putting your faith in
this crystal they're like oh that's our
film exactly
they're like way in yeah to me this
speaks to the testament of how powerful
it is to educate your children rightly
from the start yeah I mean you think
about like I mean I grew up in the in
the Christian faith my parents took me
to church as a little child and you know
I learned all the Bible stories kind of
growing up but for a big portion of my
life I walked away from God and was like
you know still forget it
but it was always in there like no
matter where I was in in in Hollywood or
whatever it was that was doing even
though it's far from anything Christian
or God it was like if you really sat
down and asked me questions that I told
you straight of what I believed you know
I mean like those seeds went into my
mind and then and then that the truth
was there and all it just needed was the
right experiences to to rebreathe me
back out of that but the devil is doing
the same thing he's beaten to the punch
basically teaching and in doctrine in
his ways of thinking to the little
children and then all of a sudden he's
just watering it with the movies he's
just watering it with the other things
as you grow older and then everybody in
life is going to experience pain at some
point in time whether it be heartache
anxiety depression you name it right and
we're all gonna seek to how do I
alleviate myself from this and then it's
like the devil's already prepped you and
then here you go
there's the here's his answers for this
one thing I've been hearing a lot about
lately it sounds really nice is
mindfulness
right can you can you touch on
mindfulness you know because I think
it's a crazy deception cuz mindfulness
is supposed to be you know clearing your
mind and being present with what you're
doing and when you look back at the
original definition of meditation it was
religious meditation on Scripture yeah
you know the Jewish Scriptures to
meditate meaning to mumble under your
breath to read aloud to think about
constantly and to be mindful by filling
your mind with Scripture full of God's
righteousness and then now mindfulness
is full of the world what you're doing
in the present moment what's going on in
your world what's going on around
consume your mind with things of
yourself right yeah I didn't think of it
that way I knew a lot of meditation has
to do with clearing your mind emptying
it out so the demons can say yeah
exactly named a vessel right there
mm-hmm that's what always kind of
bothered me about yoga yeah it was oh it
always seemed like it was like this just
like empty your mind well it's like you
know we we I believe we were vessels
right you're either filled with the Holy
Spirit or the Spirit of God or if you're
an empty vessel you can easily be filled
with something else and you know do you
remember the story that Jesus told when
he cast the demon out of the man's mind
so there's there's there's some people
asking him about you know a few things
and Jesus says you know this man swept
out as my house and the demon went away
and then when he came back he was
checking on the man and he found that
his house was swept and cleaned but
empty meaning he hadn't filled it with
something and so the demon went out and
he got seven more unclean spirits and
then he came into the man and the man
was worse off than he was before and
that tells me that if you sweep the mind
you empty yourself but you don't fill it
with God's presence or the Holy Spirit
you're an empty vessel the devil's gonna
come and he's gonna knock on it he's not
gonna not gonna do it maybe empty house
in here let's have a party and is gonna
bring us friends and you know that's how
people get full of these unclean spirits
and that's what's confusing about
Christian yoga when you tracks are a
holy yoga when you're trying to blend
the two Christianity and you'll gain the
concept of yoga because the Bible
teaches the complete opposite it says
whatever it's good whatever is pure
whatever is lovely think on these things
and come let us reason together the Lord
wants us to use our mental capabilities
and think and learn and grow not to be
empty they're not clean out the house
it's like the devil's going yeah yeah
clean that thing go ahead let me come in
you know like yeah yeah and I've seen
people in the spiritual movement that
say you know and they ask questions and
when did your spiritual journey start
and it was oh when I started doing yoga
mm-hmm this is when all these things
open up and then
and they're teaching meditation and yoga
and they're just going to yoga for
probably exercise and you know getting
stress free maybe whatever the initials
like a spiritual yeah whatever the
initial thing is it doesn't matter
it becomes the spiritual journey and
then they open themselves up and then
with chakras I did a lot of opening of
my chakras and I felt in particular when
I focused on my heart like opening my
heart chakra in particular that's when I
saw like this big shift in me and I
think that that opened up a really big
kind of doorway and you know that's when
a lot of things started taking off for
me spiritually and I think that that's
the chakras opening your chakras is it's
a really dangerous arena open they are
like this is about getting the Serpent's
to to climb up your thumbs right we know
the serpent according to the Bible is
Satan you know you know religions all
over the world have these any of the
Mayans and stuff they all see this
serpent and you know people that do DMT
and stuff a lot of them see like a
serpent and things like that but they're
not alarmed by that for some reason yeah
I wasn't yeah you cuz he said the the
first page you saw about the Kundalini
was just full of these red sir and so
you're like alright let's learn a bit
inside yeah my wife was bit by a
rattlesnake when she was younger and so
she's like deathly scared of me you know
if I find one in the yard it's like a
little tiny gardener snake she would
just literally freak out yeah some
people are not alarmed necessarily by
those kind of imageries mhm so I see a
lot of stuff here for like little kids
what about as I get a little older you
see it being propagated in books and
movies and things like that can you give
some examples you know what's that one
that autism released in Walmart and
Amazon
and Barnes and Noble's about that
straight name yeah all right what's the
name what was it the kid the kids one
that was about learning how to yeah cast
close and yet soft air Dena it is actual
a demon face on the cover of I'm selling
it in Walmart you walk into the Barnes
and Noble and they have like a whole
bookshelf of like you know all these
like teen and like kids books about all
these things meditation kind of thing
with yes oh yeah a children's book of
demons and Amazon and there was there
was also a book series one of them books
I think was made into a movie called the
Golden Compass
mysteries and the kids actually had they
referred to the animals that walked
around with him as demons and when the
little boy was being interviewed about
his acting role and stuff he was like oh
man it's like scary to think you'd be
caught without your demon there and I
was like what is this but this is like
kids stuff I've actually seen a lot of
videos lately of in school kids sitting
on the floor meditating in them in the
mudra hands and everything and this is
like something that's happening at
schools now instead of you know back
when our parents went to school there
might have been prayer oh yeah now
that's out ya know prayer but it's okay
to have a New Age meditation cuz that's
not religious and you would think like
with that movement they would be
accepting of it also if you want to pray
fine pray you wanted me to take a minute
say no they're like no prayers let's
meditate well it's because Christianity
is too judgmental of what other people
are doing Wow you know yeah it's the one
that says this is the truth I am the way
the truth not a way not a truth but the
truth people don't want to hear that
people don't want to hear that Wow
protect your children that's all I can
say man people talk about Christians
being so judgmental usually they're
pinpointing like a specific experience
or some hateful person or some angry
person came up to them who label
themselves as Christian and they just
like went ham on the person they're like
wow if that's Christianity I want
nothing to do with it little do they
know that's an individual
and they're pinning that or associating
that with the Bible the loving word of
God which is which is really unfortunate
that you know there's that correlation
you just wanted to make that comment yes
but you know it's unfair that somebody
will say I've seen this type of
Christians so-called Christians so I'm
throwing that completely out but they
don't use the same logic when it's like
well Hitler was an evolutionist
who said he was obsessed with Darwinian
evolution and that was about eugenics
let's get rid of the lower species and
and you know advanced humanity but yet
nobody's saying oh I'm never gonna look
at evolution because Hitler was an
evolutionist yeah they do it or they
take that bad experience and then they
forget about all the Christian hospitals
or the Christian like humanitarian
organizations out there trying to do
good and spread the look when there's a
natural disaster who's the first one to
go it's usually the Christian
organizations that are that are running
into the storm to help people in mission
areas that are going to third-world
countries and helping them build wells
and you know get food and build schools
and churches well we want to thank you
Leah for sharing your insights and your
experience in this New Age movement I
think if there's anything that we can
learn out of this it's be careful I mean
there's a lot of things that out there
that seem good that seem very close that
sound good you know it sounds so close
to the truth but in the end they just
lead to the way of death and so you have
to be watchful you know the Bible tells
us that Satan is going about as a
roaring lion seeking whom he may devour
so be careful what you read what you put
into your mind what you watch what what
the next YouTube video is gonna tell you
you have to be discerning so thank you
Leah for joining us and thanks for
watching and we hope to see you next
time
led live
[Music]